en mianmar se acumulan los funerales
aumenta la represión policial los
muertos y las detenciones este es el
momento en el que arrestan al periodista
de associated press tenso también crece
la represión contra el gobierno
democrático derrocado aumentaron dos
cargos contra el ex presidente wing min
por haber violado la constitución si el
big band is with bien podría ser
castigado con la cárcel por un tiempo
que puede extenderse hasta tres años
además de la posibilidad de una multa o
with wood sin embargo las protestas no
cesan en ciudades de todo el país y no
dejan de surgir símbolos como estas
faldas long y tradicionales usadas como
escudo los manifestantes no se rinden
continuaremos nuestra lucha pacífica
contra los militares hasta que la
justicia haya regresado a nuestro lado
unas demandas de justicia que son
atendidas por la comunidad internacional
llegando incluso al papá francisco quien
condenó la violencia
una vez más llegan noticias tristes de
mianmar sobre las sangrientas protestas
con pérdida de vidas me gustaría llamar
la atención de las autoridades para que
el diálogo prevalezca sobre la represión
la armonía sobre la discordia la
represión y la armonía
antes el martes se reunió la asociación
de naciones del sudeste asiático sin
grandes avances y con una petición
conjunta de moderación pero sólo con
indonesia malasia filipinas y singapur
pidiendo la liberación de la líder de la
liga nacional para la democracia aún
sanssouci detenida el 1 de febrero
cuando se produjo el golpe de estado